Om vi gör det här så bra som vi bara kan, då kommer vi liksom att tjäna pengar.
Och så länge vi tjänar pengar på att vara cirkulära, då finns det en möjlighet att vi kan inspirera andra branscher att också bli cirkulära.
Då gör vi skillnaden på riktigt.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har reda i en dess bra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Sara Idenfors till podden Makes Sweden Stronger.
Och Sara, ni har ju gjort en fantastisk resa med Västerbottensåpar.
Det är svårt att missa er framfart.
När började du känna att, fan det här kommer nog att funka?
Ja, när kände jag att det började...
Jo, men att det funkade kände vi väl ganska tidigt.
Det var egentligen pandemin som gjorde det.
För innan det hade vi en lite annan inriktning.
Vi jobbade mycket med små återförsäljare och så där.
Men sen så kom pandemin och gjorde vad den gjorde med världen.
Där och då så inser man att vi kan inte hjälpa alla och vi kan inte ändra på någon annan utan det är bara vår egen verksamhet som man kan ändra i.
Så då blev det mer fokus på e-handeln i och med att världen såg ut som den gjorde.
Då gick det nog ganska snabbt att vi kände att det här funkar ändå.
Ni säljer såpa i olika former, om jag förstår rätt.
Vad är det som gör att folk ändå har valt att gå till er och handla?
Normalt sett när e-handlare sätter sig ner och tänker vad ska jag börja sälja på nätet nu, då är det ju ofta kläder eller smycken eller smink eller den sortens produkter.
Jag tror aldrig jag har hört talas om såpa innan.
Vad är det som gör att detta verkligen funkade?
Jag tror att det är att vi har ett mission.
Det är inte bara en önskan om att sälja en massa saker på nätet, utan att det finns en tanke bakom.
Det är inte bara att vi vill stoppa in en massa saker i ett lager och sätta SKU'er på dem och lägga dem i kartonger och skicka iväg dem.
Utan det är lite mer bakom och då blir det lite intressant att följa i sociala medier och bloggar.
Då blir det få ett litet mervärde, det kanske F-rumätet kallar det mervärde, men det blir lite mer att läsa om och lite mer att sätta sig in i.
Just miljö och klimat är väldigt viktiga saker, det är få som lämnas oberörda av det ämnet.
Kan du berätta för dem som inte är så insatta i ditt bolag här, när du säger miljö och klimat och allt det här, vad är det ni egentligen gör som gör att ni sticker ut?
Det är inte alla som vet hur ni tillverkar eller var ni finns någonstans och liknande.
Ja, när det är sant.
Vi gör ju såpa av fritirolja som är återbrukad.
Alltså den fritirolja man inte längre friterar potapis i.
Den renar vi och förtvårar till såpa och det är ju sedan grunden i nästan alla andra produkter som vi gör.
Och det gör vi ju för att just det cirkulära är väldigt effektivt.
Det som frästar på vårt jordklot allra mest är ju att ta fram ny råvara.
Och det system vi har idag där nästan allt produceras, används, kastas bort, så börjar vi om.
Alltså det som är linjärt.
Det gör ju att vi får de här, du vet när man räknar fram overshoot day, när har vi det här landet konsumerat mer än vad jordklotet klarar av.
De kommer ju närmare och närmare.
Och just att vända från linjärt till cirkulärt är ju en jättestor del i att vända på den här utvecklingen.
Men så ni tar egentligen olja från frityroljan för pommes typ på lokala gatorköket, är det så det funkar?
Ja lite så och en del lokala gatorkök har fantastisk fin ordning att reda i sina kök så det går jättebra.
Men det är också finare restauranger som vi hämtar ifrån och också sådana som tillverkar på en fritt och chipsa så.
Men hur funkar det där, logistiken?
Är det liksom tankbil som kör runt och fyller på från alla?
Har ni liksom åkt runt och frågat, kan vi få er en olja?
Hur funkar det där rent logistiskt?
Ja, rent logistiskt är det ju, det är ju ett jätteprojekt.
Det är ju ett jätte nätverk av leverantörer som behöver uppfylla vissa krav.
Det går ju inte med vad som helst, det funkar till exempel inte med palmolja, då blir det inte alls sopa på våra recept, så det är ju väldigt enkelt att upptäcka ett sånt fel.
Nu har vi otroligt sällan några fel där, men ja, det är ett stort nät av leverantörer, upphämtningstider och sen så behöver ju det vi hämtar, vi behöver ju kunna se vad det är och vad det är för ursprung, så att det blir lite krav på de här leverantörerna, det blir det.
Men de får andra sidan tillbaka lite såpa så att de kan städa sin egna kök och få ett eget kretslopp, så att de skapar ju inte ett avfall där.
Vad gör de annars med den här såpan?
Den spolar man bara ut eller vad sparar de in någonting på?
Ja förlåt, oljan givetvis, ja.
Ja, nej det finns lite olika systemförde, men man får ju inte bara spola ut det, det får man inte.
Och sen en tid tillbaka så är det ju kommunerna som har dyktorsansvar för allt avfall, men det är ju också så att det är en fråga om rentjuridisk, det är en fråga om kvittblivelse.
När bestämmer man att det är skräp?
Alltså när bestämmer man att det är ett avfall?
Många har ju då någon som kommer och hämtar det och sen så går det ju ofta till någon form av förbränning.
Alltså att det blir miljödislat, eller att det är ett värmeverk eller någonting sånt där.
All förbränning innebär ju ett utsläpp.
Om man frågar oss så säger vi att det är bättre att göra en ny produkt av det istället för att hälta upp det.
Ni har ju haft en bizarr tillväxt får man ändå säga.
Nu tror jag att det senaste bokslutet låg på typ 60 någonting och jag vet att ni fortsätter växa rätt kraftigt utöver det.
Det har ju gått på bara några år.
Men för de som har lyssnat på Fedjas podd här med 0-100 med Jakob så har ju han pratat om lite om de här insamlingsproblemen med oljan.
Man försöker hitta leverantörer och grejer.
Kan man inte använda nyolja?
Eller går det emot hela din vision här?
Ja, det är klart att man kan.
Rent tekniskt kan man ju men man får ju inte alls samma effekt av det.
Okej, den ska vara använd, då är den bättre.
Ja, rent klimatmässigt.
Är den använd en gång, då alla råvaror man kan använda mer än en gång, ger en klimatmässig vinst.
Producerar man nyolja för att göra såpa av det, då har man ju skapat ett klimatavtryck.
Då har vi tagit fram en råvara.
Vi har sagt till det här jordkrotet att ta fram den här, för den här behöver jag, den ska jag göra om till såpa.
Har vi tagit fram den för att bli mat, för att sedan kunna använda sin jämn för att kunna bli såpa, så får man en helt annan siffra på det.
Jag förstår, men ni skulle kunna använda nyolja för att producera såpa, så du har ändå hållit igen tillväxten bara av den rena principfrågan, stämmer det så?
Ja, absolut.
Vi har kunnat driva på det här väldigt mycket hårdare om det har bara varit det som har varit grejen att vi ska sälja väldigt många flaskor.
Men nej, absolut inte, det gör vi inte.
Affärsidéerna är cirkulära och det ska de vara.
Det är en jävla cred, det får man ändå säga.
Det är inte många som hade hållit igen den tillväxten.
Ja, men så kan vi.
Har inte det lett till några diskussioner?
Det är klart att det har det väl kanske gjort, men har man ett koncept och så tappar man det, då har man ju ingenting kvar.
Nej, jag köper det.
Jag bara tycker att det är häftigt när folk faktiskt bibehåller sina principer.
Det är lätt att ha principer fram tills fördelarna med att inte ha principer överväger att ha principer.
Ja, när girigheten slår till.
Ja, nej men vi har ju aldrig varit riktigt i den positionen att vi har varit tvungna att göra en sån grej.
Nej, vi har liksom hållit väldigt hårt i det här.
Det har varit var vi har gjort, absolut.
Och visst, tillverkar ni allting själva?
Och ni är uppe i typ Vilhelmina eller något sånt här?
Någonstans uppe i landet?
Vi är i Vilhelmina och vi tillverkar allt skäl.
Jag är inte skurborstar och sånt där.
Allt flaskor tillverkar vi ju inte.
All produkt tillverkar vi här.
Är det också en principfråga eller är det en logistiskt smidig fråga?
Ja, precis.
Det finns så fruktansvärt många fördelar med att vara här.
Så ser man bara dem så går det ju bra.
Och det syns väl kanske också i resultatrapporterna.
Att det finns jättemånga fördelar med att vara i Vilhelmina.
Det gör det.
Hur stor del av Vilhelmina kommer du anställa om sådär 23 år?
Ja, många hoppas det.
Nej då.
Det kanske finns dem som inte vill jobba med att göra så på Vilhelmina också.
De kanske måste få fortsätta med sitt.
Men det har ju redan flyttat hit folk för att jobba här.
Det var häftigt.
Det är lite häftigt när man kör det lokalt.
Hur löser man, du nämner att folk har flyttat dit.
Hur får man folk att flytta?
Vilhelmina är ju inte navet i Sverige utan det ligger ju ändå lite.
För jag fattar att du tycker om det, men det kanske inte är jättelätt att få folk att flytta dit alltid.
Hur motiverar man människor?
Min svågel brukar säga att jag inte får prata om de här sakerna.
För om folk upptäcker hur bra det faktiskt är här, så kommer ingen att vilja vara kvar i någon stor skada och flytta hit istället.
Då blir det jobbigt säger jag.
Nej, men man erbjuder dem helt enkelt till ett vettigt jobb där man inte bara får en lön, utan man gör faktiskt en liten insats också för att det blir en lite bättre värld.
Sen har vi ett väldigt bra arbetsklimat, ett bra ställe att jobba på.
Vi är ganska många nu men det är fortfarande ett kompisier.
Man har liksom, börjar man här så då har man, ja man har ju drygt 30 polare som håller ryggen liksom.
Så det är inte dåligt på det sättet.
Det är ett trevligt och ett bra jobb så det har verkligen inte varit ett problem att få folk att jobba här.
Vad ärligt.
När man har, får du säga någonting om vad ni kommer landa på i år?
Ja, det kan jag väl.
Alltså ja, vi kommer, vi har ju baxat det här en bit över hundra men hur långt, hur långt över hundra, det får vi väl se.
Det är några dagar kvar.
När man har den tillväxten då, det momentumet som liksom inte har stannat av, hur går tankarna?
Liksom, vad, tänker du så här fyra år framåt i tiden eller försöker du mest hantera situationen som uppstår och hur försvinner visionsbilden bort?
Är detta något du vill göra i 10 år, 20 år eller vad vill du att det ska bli?
Tänker man på andra marknader?
Kan vi inte få följa med in i huvudet där lite grann och bara fatta hur man tänker?
Hur lång podd har du?
Nä men kör på det.
Nej men det är klart att när man växer i den här takten det är ju liksom inte vanligt.
Det är en ovanlig situation att hamna i och när man hamnar i den situationen så blir det ju såklart mycket att hantera.
Det gäller ju att parera och hantera det för att inte göra någon typ av dikeskörning där.
Då är det absolut viktigaste, det som är prio ett är att behålla den här goda företagskulturen och att alla vill gå till det här jobbet.
Allt som är tärande och negativt måste man bromsa och distansera verksamheten.
Själv ifrån, var ska man orka med det här?
Då behövs det.
När det växer så här, så innebär det en hel del stress.
När man lägger på stress på saker och ting, det är då det kan börja kärva till sig på det området.
Det är det absolut viktigaste att kunna hantera den här tillväxten, så att alla vill gå till jobbet och göra sitt absolut bästa.
Sen framåt så har vi en väldigt tydlig vision, och det vet liksom alla om.
Alla som jobbar här har det.
Vi pratar om det varje vecka, varje fredag så har vi ett snack om att om vi gör det här så bra som möjligt, om vi gör det här så bra som vi bara kan, då kommer vi liksom att tjäna pengar.
Och så länge vi tjänar pengar på att vara cirkulära, då finns det en möjlighet att vi kan inspirera andra, andra branscher att också bli cirkulära.
Och när det börjar hända, då gör vi skillnaden på riktigt.
För frityroilja det är ändå bara en pytteliten del.
Det finns väldigt mycket material som kan man kasta bort idag, som inte återanvänds.
Och kan vi visa folk att, ja, det här med att vara cirkulär, och det här med återanvändar och vara, det verkar ju vara lönsamt, då kommer det att hända grejer.
Då kommer vi att göra en stor skillnad, en verkreskill.
Är det det som är ditt övergripande mål här?
För det är ju lite, jag bara tänker, det påverkar hur man tar beslut i företaget.
Är det att vara någon sorts inspirationsmodell för andra, eller är det för att driva bolaget?
Det är två väldigt olika sätt att driva bolag på.
Nej, det är det väl egentligen inte.
Jag tycker att det är ganska lika, enligt aktiebolagslagen har vi ett uppdrag att tjäna pengar till ägarna.
Om vi tjänar pengar till aktieägarna och det syns, om vi då gör det och är tydliga med att det här gör vi genom att vara cirkulär, då kommer vi att inspirera andra till att göra samma sak.
Om det syns och karsh att någon tjänar pengar, då är det ju många andra som har hakat på dritt.
Kan ni se att andra har hakat på redan mot...
Har du dikt upp många kopier här i de senaste två åren?
Nej, jag menar inte att man behöver kopiera.
Det räcker ju alltså vilken bransch som helst, om man vill återanvända gamla lastbilstick.
Folk är lata, de vill ju kopiera er.
Om de ser att man hittar inte på något nytt, man tar ju exakt samma.
Då får vi önska dem lycka till.
Det här är ganska jobbigt och det är ganska svårt, och det är inte speciellt glamouröst.
Vi har väl ett litet försprång där.
Men det finns otroligt mycket material i den här världen.
Vi producerar massor av grejer och kassar bort dem och börjar om igen.
När vi kan sno på det, när någon annan tänker att såhär gör jag, jag undrar om jag kan tjäna en slant på att använda det här.
Det kanske blir jättebra.
Börja fundera ut egna system.
Då vänder det.
Det finns ju folk som jobbar med att investera pengar, mycket pengar i andra grejer.
Vissa av dem har redan identifierat fossila bränslen som spranded assets.
Det här är en verksamhet som bygger på fossila bränslen, men här är det ingen mening att investera, för det är ju det, det är inte i tiden.
När vi kommer dit, att man börjar minsa att det linjärna kanske också har gått på grund, det kanske också har spranded asset.
Då har vi kommit en bit, då har vi gjort något.
Du pratar lite i början här om, ni har ju en viss storytelling i detta, kan du ta oss med lite tillbaka till början?
Vad kommer den här såpa idén ifrån, hur började bolaget, hur började recepten, hur började tillverkningen?
Kan vi bara få en liten nostalgitripp?
Nostalgitripp tillbaka.
Back to the good old days.
Tillbaka till 1926.
Ja, det är faktiskt så att min gammal farmor Fredrika Hellmersson, hon bodde i en by utanför Vilminnas med till Hornsjö, och där fick man väldigt sent el.
Till exempel var självhushållningen väldigt hög grad.
Det påverkar väl, men hon var också väldigt noga med att lära sina barn och barnbarn.
Min mamma hade 36 kusiner.
Alla fick lära sig att, har du någonting, slänga inte bort det, utan då gör du någonting av det.
Allt man har är att det traktas som en tillgång.
Hon gjorde ju skjuter till sina barn av mjörrsäckar, som man då fick med ångbåt som kom efter Malmö i sjön.
Så inte ens mjörrsäck slängde man bort på den tiden.
Men såpa gjorde hon och hon gjorde det lite extra bra.
Hon var känd för att hon hade en egen metod och det var väldigt bra såpa.
Man gjorde ju såpa på många gårdar, men hon hade ett lite eget sätt.
Så jag har ju vuxit upp med att höra att så bra såpa som farma gjorde, det finns aldrig mer.
Det kommer vi aldrig att få tag i.
Så det har jag hört hela min uppväxt, att så bra blir det aldrig igen.
Sedan gick det fram till 2006, när vi tog över och började driva Hotell Vilhelmina, som hade ett ganska ordentligt kök och restaurang egentligen.
Det blev mycket frityrolja över.
Då var det inte så långt bort med tanken att kunde farmor med sin vedeldade grita göra såpass så bra så att ingen har hört talas om att det finns en så bra produkt nu.
Kunde hon göra det då av fårfett som egentligen var kassat och inte dugas av mat.
Då måste vi kunna göra såpa på det här.
Det var nämligen så att det kom en liten farbror med en lastbil och hämtar det där och körde det till Murmansk när vi började.
Det kändes ju som hår i huvudet så kan man inte bete oss.
Min morfar levde ju då, han hade ju såklart kvar recept på en liten lapp där och vi justerade det där tills det blev såpa.
Sedan kopade vi såpa i sex år i källaren på hotellet och använde det bara där inne.
Det användes bara internt i verksamheten under de åren.
Alla som jobbade där tyckte ju att den var väldigt bra.
Alla hade ju samma uppfattning om produkten.
Att det här är mycket bättre än det man kan köpa.
Så att det här behöver vi göra mer av.
Speciellt när det var jobbigt, när det var så här fräcktkåpor och du vet hur fett.
Och snart det kan bli i ett restaurangkök då behöver man storstad.
Då ville ju alla ha den så.
Sen gick det till att vi sålde den verksamheten.
Det kändes lite synd att släppa det här igen.
Då byggde vi den första lilla fabriken och startade att registrera in det.
Man måste registrera in det hos kemikalieinspektionen för att ens få sälja det.
Och det gjorde vi.
2014 gjorde vi det.
Men det var ju fortfarande bara på hobbynivå.
Och det var det ända fram till 2022 egentligen.
Då drog det igång med covid eller vad var det som hände där?
Ja det handlade i mitten av pandemin och sen var det också så att vi kände att för då, 2022 tror jag att vi omsatte 7 miljoner ungefär.
Och då kände vi att det här är ju inte en mysig hobby längre.
Det är lite för mycket för att vara det och det är lite för lite för att vara ett riktigt jobb åt oss allihop här.
Men vi såg också att det funkar ju.
Det funkar att sälja det här och skicka på det i paket.
Ihandel funkar och sociala medier funkar som annonseringskanal och sådär.
Men vi klarar inte av det själva, vi är lite för...
Vi är för få och för små, vi behöver hjälp.
Och då tog vi in en ny del lägare och det var ju Porridge Group, som kom in och skalade upp hela den här e-handelsgrejen.
Var det bara glädjande när det började skala upp, eller vad blev flaskhalsarna där i själva uppskalningen?
Vad blev problemen när man går från 7 miljoner till 20 miljoner, eller vad man ska säga, och sen till 60.
Det måste ju vara rätt stor produktionskapacitet som ni måste hantera rätt fort.
Ja, det är det och...
Ja, alltså egentligen, vi har ju inte köpt en kemfabrik.
Det var inte så att vi köpte en kemfabrik som råkade stå tom med Vilhelmina, sen så bara började vi fixa lite här inne.
Utan, vi har ju byggt allt.
Det fanns ju ingenting.
Så vi har ju fått bygga en fabrik eftersom.
Så att trögheten har ju funnits i det.
Sen så visst har vi ju haft ibland att vi har fått in lite för lite olja, men det är ju bara, alltså det är bara timmar som fattas.
Det är ju bara jobb.
Någon behöver sätta sig att kontakta fler, göra ett schema, hämta upp och testa, få igång det samarbete.
Det är ju inte, det är inte jättesvårt i sådana bitar, det är bara det att det är massa jobb som ska göras.
Sen det som har varit störst tröghet i, det är ju att när vi bestämmer oss för att nu ska vi växa den här delen, då säger leverantörer av en kollaborativ robot till exempel att jättetack för den beställningen, den kommer om sex månader.
Inte den kommer nästa vecka.
Mugga är inte riktigt så.
Trögheten är ju mer i att få sådana saker på plats.
Kan du känna en frustration, hur stor frustration känner du?
Hur lång är den här resan för dig?
Känner du att det här är min läggelseresa, jag ska göra detta hela mitt liv?
Eller känner du en sådan, ja fan vi vet inte när det tar slut, så jag måste göra detta nu svinfort under några år.
Jag har ju aldrig fått vara med på en sådan här resa.
Min resa har ju varit extremt linjär och relativt trappstegstråkig.
Det här är en väldigt fascin...
Jag undrar hur man blir i huvudet när det här händer.
Ja, nej men det kanske var fel på det där huvudet från början då, jag vet inte.
Nej, det...
Ja, det står väl skrivet att högmod går före fall och ödmjukhet går före ära.
Det är väl så det står.
Och det är väl egentligen inte jättesvårt att...
Man behöver ha den där hög...
Alltså, man behöver ha ödmjukheten absolut för det här är det som du säger, att det här händer ju inte alla.
Det gör det inte.
Men det har väl lite att göra med att vi är ju Vilhelmina också.
Det är ingen större skillnad egentligen.
I vårat liv är det ingen större skillnad.
Det är bara det att man känner att man vill bara och tror ett rädd om den här processen, att man vill att det ska gå rätt till och att det ska bli så bra som möjligt.
Sen har vi nog inte drabbats av något extremt övermod.
Snarare att det är väldigt mycket jobb att balansera det här.
Från det att man bestämmer sig att nu ska vi investera och skala upp den här delen, då är det ju ett halvår som man behöver balansera alla produkter innan de kan möta den här tillväxtdelen, det man har investerat idag för att kunna producera mer.
Så det är ett väldigt räknande.
Vad är det som stoppar er från att ta in en riktigt stor aktör och bara skala ut detta och få ut i varenda affär i hela Norden?
En annan fabrik tänker du, White Label är det?
Vi har ingen aning men att säga att det skulle komma in någon stor aktör och bara säga tja, vi kan producera hur mycket som helst, vi kan distribuera detta, du ska vara ansiktet utåt för det här och vi kommer signa upp med varenda snabbmatskedja i Norden och så kommer vi bara pumpa ut detta och slå in.
Finns det några sådana tankar att bara, nu drar vi igång detta fullblon liksom.
Det är ju målet att vi ska återbruka så mycket som möjligt, däremot så tror jag att det är ganska svårt att bara flytta på allt det här till en annan fabrik.
Det går nog kanske inte för de flesta fabriker tar ju in ny råvara som man ber veta att göra någonting av.
Så att det är ju, av vad jag vet så finns det ju ingen som har byggt en sån här fabrik i den här storläkaren.
Och det tog ju sin lilla tid så att det kan nog vara svårt att bara flytta den.
Jag gillar att du säger inte att man kan sälja mer, du säger att vi kan återbruka mer.
Har du alltid varit så extremt god?
Jag vet inte vad miljömedveten, du vet hela den här.
När jag säger att man kan skala upp det här ordentligt, och säger att det är målet att återbruka så mycket som möjligt.
Det är ju ett annat sätt att sälja så mycket som möjligt.
Jag tänker ju försäljning och omsättning.
Du tänker nog först återbruk och det är ju två lite skilda synsätt.
Jag kan ju fascineras av ditt sätt att se på det.
När kom din intresse?
Jag fick ju det här.
Jag hade turen att få det här från det att jag var barn.
Vi har ju haft en otroligt privilegierad uppväxt.
Det är få som har fått de möjligheterna att växa upp som vi har gjort.
Och få med oss att så här gör vi.
Så här ser vi på saker och ting.
Vi kastar inte bort grejer.
Vi gör om det till något.
Sen är det nog hela grejen att man har fått den här möjligheten att växa upp som vi har gjort helt enkelt.
Det är ju inte alla förunnat att se hur saker och ting hänger ihop.
Det är ganska direkta grejer här.
När jag växte upp så hade jag ju inga problem att se kopplingen mellan fisk och fiskpinne.
Jag trodde inte att den dök upp i affären bara sådär.
Man lever ju ganska nära natur på ett sätt, så det blir ganska självklart, det är inte så svårt att förstå.
Och sen att vi fick det från farmorna allihop då.
Min mamma fick det och alla hennes kusiner fick samma uppfoströrande, samma information och samma bakgrund.
Så att, ja, det är någonting vi bara har fått.
Sen hade min mamma en kusin som heter Lasse, som bodde på Lidingö.
Stockholm, han var här uppe varje höst.
Och han hade en sjukdom som gjorde att han hade svårt med fysiskt arbete.
Så han ägnade sig väldigt väldigt mycket med att läsa.
Läsa om miljöproblem, det var inte så mycket klimat på den tiden men miljö.
Och jag älskade verkligen att lyssna då han pratade.
Och det är fortfarande lite så att jag är bransch och hör man folk säga men det här är ett nytt rön, en ny idé.
Och då kan jag känna att jag har hört det för 30 år sedan.
Det kom därifrån.
Så det är ingenting som har hänt.
Jag har inte bara blivit sån utan den och omständigheterna.
Hur lycklig är du att du ändå får driva ett bolag som växer och som samtidigt gör någonting som du verkligen tycker om.
Det måste ju vara en fantastisk invest.
Jo, det måste man påminna sig själva och jobba lite med.
Att känna in på något sätt att det verkligen blir lite bättre.
Vi gör någonting som blir lite bättre faktiskt.
Så de där dagarna när man har jobbat så att man är helt slut i huvudet och det ger ont i kroppen överallt så känns det ju ändå gött på något vis.
Exakt, jag fattar.
Har ni tagit in fler investerare än på Robert Group?
Ja, men det var samtidigt.
Vi har en kille som heter Daniel Darnhagen som är med också.
Känner de samma grej?
Upplevde du att ni är kindred spirits i detta?
Eller var detta mer människor med kompetens inom andra områden?
Eller hur gick dialogerna där?
De har ju kompetens inom det, de är ju svinjuktiga på sina grejer.
De är ju jättebra på det.
Sen kan ju jag tjata om sånt här hur länge som helst.
Jag pratar ju till så att folk slutar lyssna, går hem, stänger öron.
Är tanken att du ska vara den stora ambassadören för Västerbottens sopa, du känns ju som att du passar in i det här varumärket.
Hur många av era kunder känner till dig?
Eller hittar de bara råvaran för att det är en bra produkt?
Eller är det storyn man tycker om?
Jag tror att det är lite olika.
Det är lite olika, en del är väldigt resultatfokuserade.
Hur bra blir det min trall?
Eller hur min syras badrumsdörrar blev som nya?
Sen skiter vi i resten.
Det spelar ju inte så stor roll heller, huvudsaken att man väljer någonting som är bra då.
Så är ju det okej.
Men en del...
Nej, en del attraheras nog kanske av storyn och bakgrunden och hållbarhetstänket och så där.
Vi är ju ganska transparenta också.
På hemsidan finns det LCA-analyser och ISO 14001 som vi har som miljöstyrningssystem.
Man kan ju se massa sådana saker.
Vi har till och med en prototyp på digitala produktpass.
Man kan se alla värden för en produkt.
Nu är det ju inte lag på det här än i Sverige och det finns väl inte ens någon standard inom EU för att få hur de här digitala produktpassen ska se ut.
Men det har ändå en liten prototyp på plats att man kan se.
Så de som är intresserade hittar nog det.
Och de som bara vill att det ska funka hittar det.
Och så finns det nog ett gäng som känner att jag kanske inte vill ha alla de här kemikalierna inne i mitt hus i närheten av mina barn och djur.
Så jag kanske ska väga något mer hälsosamt.
Så det också kan nog kanske vara ett argument.
Hur många tror du bara tycker om Sara då?
Ja men hon verkar skön, henne vill jag handla av.
Ja alltså jag tror att det finns en del som tycker jag är ett spam i deras flöde som dyker upp av och av för mycket också.
Det finns nog kanske lika många som tycker att jag bara star.
Jag fattar.
Under den här, vi säger slutfasen av resan som vi har gjort, om vi hoppar över de här första sju åren när ni fick koka såpa och inte växa lika kraftigt.
Men under de här senaste åren, vad är det som har gått?
Det gick inte så jävla bra liksom.
Vilka grejer har, vilka felbeslut har ni tagit under de här två tre åren när det verkligen har tagit fart?
Ja, vi har säkert tagit många felbeslut, men förhoppningsvis inte så många jättestora.
Sen är jag ganska förtjust när man har bra marginaler.
Jag tycker inte så här jättemycket om när man gör saker för att göra saker som inte ger något.
I alla processer så måste varje moment vara lönsamt.
Är det inte det, då måste det ju bort.
Hos oss blir olönsamma moment inte så jättelångvariga.
Jag har ju nördat ganska rejält i det Toyota-Voy och Linne-principer.
Nu låter det väldigt girigt om man säger att man kan tjäna pengar och spara pengar, men det är också så att det blir en väldigt mycket bättre arbetsdag om man mäter allt väldigt noga och plockar bort moment som inte ger mot.
Om man stoppar saker i kartonger för att sen ställa dem på ett lager för att sen packa upp dem igen för att sen stoppa dem i en låda och skicka iväg.
Då bör man ju lite kritiskt titta på varje del.
Varför gör jag det här?
Varför håller vi på att stoppa det här i en kartong och flytta de här kartongerna och skjutsa runt den om det inte behövs?
Pocka bort dem bara.
Varför har vi datasystem som tillför dem någonting eller är det bara ett arbetsmoment som egentligen inte tillför något?
Gör vi saker bara för att mata ett datasystem eller gör vi saker för att det är produktivt?
Vad är liksom, vad är våran huvuduppgift här?
Vi ska göra så att vi ska lägga den i en kartong och skicka den till en kund.
Vi räknade ut någonstans här i somras att vi hade sparat in 700 arbetstimmar vid det tillfället på att inte skanna allt.
Ja men man måste skanna allt för att det ska bli exakt rätt i lager.
Det kanske alla andra gör men vi gör inte så för det tar inte 700 timmar att inventera ett lager.
Jag älskar det, jag köper det rakt av.
Det är skitbra.
Vad är din tidigare erfarenhet?
Du berättar om det här med hotellet.
Var det samma filosofi där?
Vad har du för erfarenhet tidigare?
Nej, då var det bara att försöka vara vaken så länge som möjligt.
Det behövs inte mer än en jobb då.
Nej, det här med Lina och Toyota Way och sånt, de har konsulter som är väldigt duktiga som hjälper oss med det, men jag har de här sista åren nördat något helt enormt i sånt här.
Det är faktiskt jättespännande och det visar sig i resultatrapporterna också.
Det syns i några år efter att det är slut.
Att plocka bort onödiga dyra moment, då blir det bra marginaler helt enkelt.
Från början kan det låta både närligt och tråkigt här hemställda med att dela upp en arbetstimme i 100 000 enheter och se vad vi gör fast vi inte behöver vad vi gör som stavar i den här arbetstimmen.
Det är ju inte för att folk ska jobba fortare så i fast första hand, utan det är för att man ska inte göra onödiga saker.
Gör man inte onödiga saker, då blir det en ganska bra arbetsdag och när åren är slut så blir det en ganska bra marginal.
Men då gäller det att man inte kussa runt grejer och betala för saker som inte ger någonting.
Så det är klart att där får man ju vara lite häxansurtant och ifrågasätta varför gör vi det här och varför betalar vi för det här om det inte ger något.
När du säger häxansurtant, är det för att folk har sagt det i förhandlingarna eller?
Ja men det, jo men alltså e-handeln är ganska...
Ja jo.
Jo men det händer väl att man liksom, det är väl kanske inte jättemysigt men man måste ju ifrågasätta varje utgiftspost och varje grej man gör.
Varför står vi och varför flyttar vi det här, varför lyfter vi det här, varför står vi i den här kartongen, varför gör vi så här.
Men till slut så blir det ju faktiskt bättre om man ser till att plocka bort sådana där saker som inte ger någonting helt enkelt.
Det har ju, det har man väldigt mycket i Whiteboards till exempel.
Industrin har ju massa olika system och programvaror och grejer man kan använda, men många ganska stora fabriker, väldigt mycket större än våran, har ju plockat bort och gått tillbaka till Whiteboards.
Just för att det tar för mycket tid av personal, det blir för många irritationer, för många datorer som krånglar.
Så då plockar man bort det helt enkelt.
Ju färre datorer som kan krångla, ju färre skrivare som kan krångla, desto mer tid sparar vi på det.
Och det är inte kul för personal att behövas att körva med saker som inte funkar.
Det som inte funkar ska bort.
Fullt rimligt, det är lätt att säga men det ska ju göras också.
Ja det ska ju göras och e-handeln är liksom, det är en ung, du behöver ju inte hålla på med det så länge, det har ju inte gått.
Historiskt sett, om man tittar tillbaka så är det inte så många år som vi har kunnat jobba med e-handel.
Däremot, annan industri, vi har ju tillverkat bilar väldigt länge.
Där har ju folk haft en enorm massa år på sig att räkna ut, hur gör vi det här på snabbast och bäst sätt.
Men sen så finns det några sådana här, alla e-handlare gör såhär, så här måste vi vara, nej det kanske vi inte måste om vi tänker efter.
Det finns ju annan industri som hjälper ett annat sätt.
Vi tittar på det lite grann kanske.
Har du några fler sådana exempel förutom att man inte måste scanna allting?
Jag har massa sådana exempel.
Hos oss är det inte hemmeligt heller, utan det är bara att köpa bok under Toyota Way, så står ju allting där om man orkar läsa den.
Men hos oss liknar ju, paketering till exempel liknar ju väldigt mycket ett monteringsbord med materialfasader och den typen av upplägg.
Det är inte så mycket rulla på en vagn och scanna med en scanner, det har vi liksom effektiviserat bort.
Jag förstår.
Det här var kul, spännande.
När du kollar på resan framåt här, vad kan du se är de stora riskmomenten, vilka plateauer tror du kan uppstå?
Har du funderat i de tankarna?
Det finns en massa riskmoment överallt.
De största är väl att vi inte skulle klara av den här tillväxten, att vi inte skulle kunna behålla den här företagsformaten vi har, den här goda andan där alla hjälps åt, utan att vi skulle hamna i någon slags, att det börjar bli ett jobbigt man går och stämplar in och stämplar ut.
Då skulle vi ju inte kunna behålla den här tillväxttakten och den effektiviteten vi har om vi skulle tappa där.
Så att vi måste hålla nogsam koll på den här tillväxten och vara medvetna om att det är speciellt, det är sällsynt och det är jobbigt och vi klarar det bara om hjälps åt.
Hur håller man koll på det?
Börja med varje fredag med att liksom fråga alla, är alla fajn nu?
Ja.
Är vi fortfarande på banan?
Ja det gör vi faktiskt.
Vi har varje fredag med vår platsgäst.
Vi har en hand om att checka av allt det, gå igenom vad som har gått bra, vad som har gått mindre bra under veckan.
Vi hjälps åt med saker och ting och sen så har vi lite så här, vi har någonting som vi kallar för hinderbanan, där det är liksom ett kvantifierat mål, att man ska försöka hitta hinder eller sånt man tycker är jobbigt i arbetet och komma med ett förslag på en lösning.
Vi har ett mål, jag tror att vi satt att alla ska försöka komma med 12 stycken sådana varor per år.
Att alla som jobbar här försöker identifiera problem och komma med ett förslag på en lösning och sen så far vi in den där protokollen och ta upp den.
Här är det någon som har identifierat att det här är ett problem, hur kan vi lösa det?
Så löser vi det så fort som möjligt.
Sparar folk problem då?
Istället för att ta upp två problem i januari så sparar de ett i februari.
Och så om någon råkar säga det tidigare än dem under februari så före där i cirkeln så bara fan den har jag skrivit upp.
Det är mitt problem i februari.
Nej, nej, den sitter utanför fikarummet.
Så att man går förbi den minst tre gånger om dagen och så uppmanar de sig, men har ni kommit på någonting nu så då skriver ni upp det här problemet och har ni ett förslag på en lösning skriv det också och sen sade Farslin i protokollet att ta sig upp så fort som möjligt och så försöker vi få in i våra QLH-mål, hur många som möjligt.
Jag gillar det, du säger företagskulturen som den stora platon eller svårigheten i tillväxten är, är du så god i verkligheten?
Jag blir alltid lite skeptisk när folk svarar trevligt på alla frågor.
Om jag skulle fråga dina kollegor, hade de sagt samma sak då?
Men Sara, hon kommer alltid hit och kollar hur vi mår, inte ifall maskinerna klarar av en fördubbling.
Nej, jag är inte så god.
Det är klart att vi kollade ju också allting.
Det är klart att vi kollade allt.
Nej, det kanske låter så som att vi har ju verkligen den här morsättningen.
Det har vi ju men sen så, nej, som jag sa, det står ju aktiebolagslagen.
Det är vad vi ska göra.
Vi ska tjäna pengar till ögarna så att nej, det sticker jag inte understående med att det är det vi gör till ett aktiebolag.
Vi tjänar pengar men vi behöver ju inte bete oss illa för den skur.
Och sen så finns det väl faktiskt också bra med evidens på att mår folk dåligt så blir det ingen det blir inga bra marginaler på det.
Mår folk bra trivs på arbetsplatsen och kan man stoppa in det där lilla extra som behövs.
Vi har ju också säsongsvariationer som heter det duga.
Här har vi ju toppar och darar i försäljningen och ska man klara sånt, då behöver man ju ett gäng som känner att nu är jädrands, nu är det vår, nu drar trallssäsongen igång så nu taggar vi till här allihop.
Jag är bara lite intresserad också av hur din roll har förändrats genom åren här för att jag gissar att din arbetsroll ser lite annorlunda ut i dag jämfört med för bara kanske fyra år sedan.
Hur har den omställningen sett ut?
Ja det har varit en ganska stor omställning för 20-22.
Det var ju bara en hobby då.
Det var Magnus och Maggan som var anställda i bolaget, jag hade inte ens löne härifrån så på den nivån var det.
Men sen när vi drog igång, då var jag väldigt operativ.
Alla har stoppat in mycket timmar här.
All släkt och alla vänner vi har fick också där i början.
När vi är i det här, nu väntar vi på en maskin, men vi har jättemycket vi behöver göra innan den här maskinen kommer.
Då har vi haft släkt och vänner deluxe som har hoppat in och hjälpt till.
Alla har ju offrat höger och kvällar på det här.
Men jag har ju också stoppat in alla timmar jag har haft i det.
Men nu så har det väl ändrat sig till att jag är mer strategisk än operativ.
Däremot så går jag till jobben nästan varje dag i arbetskläder.
Det gör jag ju för jag har ju ändå en tanke varje dag om att idag så kommer jag hinna ställa mig någonstans och göra lite fysisk, praktisk nytta här.
Vi kör arbetskläder idag också.
Sen så blir det ju mer och mer sällan att det misslyckas.
Men det är ju min ambition nästan varje dag.
En del dagar så säger jag såhär nej men jag har möten från morgon till kväll det kommer aldrig gå.
Men de allra första dagarna så har jag ändå den ambitionen att jag ska hinna göra någon fysisk, praktisk nytta.
Jag förstår precis den känslan.
Alltid när jag åker ut i lagret har jag mina snickarbyxor på mig.
För att jag har någon sorts illusion om att jag är med och monterar upp någon cykel här eller jag ska vara med och fixa den här lådan eller vad som helst.
Men jag bara väntar på det tillfället när någon i personalen bara säger, Olle vad fan håller du på med typ?
Sluta fejk.
Tror du att du är med i gänget här eller?
Gå nu.
Jag lever i min lilla, min lilla vackra dröm fortfarande.
Sara vilket fantastiskt bolag du har byggt upp.
Jag håller alla tummar jag kan för att detta bara fortsätter mala på.
Och ett enormt tack för att du tog lite tid att vara med här i podden.
Så vi får höra lite om din resa.
Ja men tusen tack för att jag fick vara med.
Jättekul och som sagt vad jag kan ju prata om de här sakerna hur länge som helst.
Jag skulle gissa att vi kommer nog att få höra i fler poddar och på fler event i framtiden.
Det är nog inte sista podden du joinar.
Är det Sara att det är någon som orkar och vill lyssna på mitt snack om cirkulär produktion så då pratar jag.
Ring Sara om du vill veta mer.
Tack så mycket.
Mer om cirkulärt ja.
Då pratar jag hur länge som helst.
Jag köper det.
Jag bara tycker att det är häftigt när folk faktiskt bibehåller sina principer.
Det blir lätt att ha principer fram tills fördelarna med att inte ha principer överväger att ha principer.